seven-year-old Saddam Noor had dreams
and ambitions his family says he wanted
to join the forces which protect his
village he was killed in the latest
cross-border shelling in
pakistan-administered Kashmir as usual
India and Pakistan accuse each other of
what they call unprovoked aggression and
violation of the ceasefire Pakistan's
military spokesman tweeted that
retaliatory fire killed six Indian
soldiers the day after the shelling from
the Indian side we witnessed more shells
landing on the civilian population in
that Tapani sector of district court lay
a few homes were damaged
Kashmiri say life comes to a standstill
every time tension escalates on the
border indiscriminate firing continues
from India they target civilians and
kill innocent people as you can see we
are a few kilometers from the border you
can still hear their guns people rushed
to see what happened to their property
when the firings subsided Bashir is a
farmer he refuses to move because he
would lose his land and livelihood are
apparent there was no way to run under
heavy shelling from the Indian side we
was scared and tried to hide in the
basement when mortar shells were landing
everywhere this year at least 33
civilians have been killed in artillery
and mortar shelling in
pakistan-administered Kashmir and Indian
officials also say civilians have
suffered on their side it's difficult
for villagers near the line of control
the dividing line between the two sides
everyday activities such as going to
school or the shops becomes impossible
we were coming from katli town towards
battle sector on the line of control we
heard there was heavy shelling from the
Indian side so we took shelter in the
basement of a mosque the foreign
minister says Pakistan will be taking
Kashmir's cash to the International
Court of Justice but people here have
their doubts that there will be any
outcome there's mounting anger in
pakistan-administered Kashmir not just
against the shelling across the line of
control but also about the plight of
Kashmiri stranded on the Indian side
Osama bin jarred al Jazeera was off
Rabat